[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend nicht wenige in
Europa fragen sich was hat ihn geritten
den französischen Präsidenten einige
Außenpolitiker nennen es sogar naiv und
gefährlich auf seinem Rückflug aus China
wo Frankreich etliche wirtschaftsdeals
abgeschlossen hat hat macron von einer
zu großen Abhängigkeit Europas gewarnt
nicht von China sondern von den USA ist
es in politisches Kalkül ist es
Inszenierung jedenfalls sorgen seine
Aussagen für sehr viel Verärgerung
Florian neuhahn versucht Klarheit zu
schaffen
das ist Emanuel macron wie er seine
China-Reise sieht Politik im tiktok
Style bei Freunden ein Video seines
per-teams das so auch die chinesische
Propaganda hätte veröffentlichen können
und das ist was andere zu dieser Reise
sagen
das ist der Katastrophe in der in der in
der in der Wahrnehmung Europas
international was macron gesagt hat dass
uns der Konflikt um Taiwan nicht zu
interessieren braucht ist schlichtweg
falsch
der Schaden den er anrichtet ist groß in
den USA aber vor allem in Osteuropa
was da so große Wellen schlägt ist
weniger der Besuch selbst sondern ein
Interview das macron auf dem Rückflug
gibt darin warnt er Europa vor einer
vermeintlichen Falle im konfliktum Teil
waren zu sehr auf eine Seite gezogen zu
werden und zwar die der USA Zitat das
Schlimmste wäre zu denken dass wir
Europäer Mitläufer sein und uns dem
amerikanischen Rhythmus und einer
chinesischen Überreaktion anpassen
Europa als Vasall der USA kein
Versprecher Makros präsentim hatte diese
Sätze genauso autorisiert und so wird
das Interview als Abgrenzung von den USA
verstanden manch einer wie Polens
Ministerpräsidenten reagiert subtil mit
einer Klarstellung
mit den USA ist die absolute Grundlage
unserer Sicherheit
manch anderer wie der republikanische
US-Senator Marco Rubio kontert plakativ
mit einer gegendrohung
wir geben gerade sehr viel Geld von
amerikanischen Steuerzahlern in der
Ukraine aus für einen europäischen Krieg
ich war immer dafür dass wir unsere
Verbündeten unterstützen aber wenn
unsere Verbündeten sich jetzt nicht
einmal zwischen den USA und China
entscheiden könnten dann sollten wir
vielleicht sagen wir kümmern uns um die
Bedrohung aus China und um Taiwan und
ihr kümmert euch alleine um Europa
der so kritisierte ist heute in den
Niederlanden der nächste Staatsbesuch
macron wird empfangen von König Wilhelm
Alexander hält später eine Grundsatzrede
über Europa zu seinem Interview darin
kein Wort nur ein Nebensatz der
irgendwie passt
wir wollen offen sein wir wollen
Verbündete und Freunde aber wir wollen
sie immer selbst aussuchen können
Emmanuel macron selbst hat jetzt wohl
ein paar Freunde weniger und Europa ein
altes Problem eine gemeinsame Haltung zu
finden
interessant sind die Einlassungen
macrons auch vor dem Hintergrund der
dreitägigen Militärübungen Chinas rund
um Taiwan ausgerechnet jetzt eine
Annäherung Chinas zu suchen und eine
gleichzeitige Abkehr Amerikas wie viele
macrons Worte ja deuten das sorgt für
Unmut unter anderem auch beim
cdu-außenexperten Norbert Röttgen mit
dem ich gleich genau darüber sprechen
werde und während aber jetzt hier die
Diskussion über macron laufen ist heute
das größte Militärmanöver der USA mit
den Philippinen angelaufen im
Südchinesischen Meer Miriam Steiner über
einen Schulterschluss der ein klares
Signal an China aber auch
geschichtsträchtig ist
von den Wolkenkratzern von Manila bis zu
diesem stillen Ort sind es nur wenige
Schritte
jedes Kreuz erinnert an einen von mehr
als 17.000 Soldaten die während des
Zweiten Weltkriegs hier starben es ist
ein Mahnmal dass sich Geschichte nicht
wiederholen soll
für George McArthur ist der ein Symbol
für die 70-Jährige Freundschaft zwischen
den beiden Ländern und ihren Armeen die
jedes Jahr zusammen trainieren
[Musik]
die Philippinen und die Vereinigten
Staaten arbeiten während der Body
katan-übung zusammen um die
gegenseitigen Fähigkeiten zu stärken die
Streitkräfte zu modernisieren und die
Zusammenarbeit zu verbessern so leisten
wir einen Beitrag für eine sichere und
florierende Region im Indopazifik
Atan übersetzt bedeutet das so viel wie
Schulter an Schulter
18.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind
dieses Mal dabei so viele wie noch nie
wenige Wochen nach dem Präsident
Ferdinand Markus Junior den USA zugesagt
hat zusätzlich zu bereits vorhandenen
Stützpunkten vier weitere Militärbasen
nutzen zu können drei davon auf der
Nordinsel keine 400 km von Taiwan
entfernt sozusagen als Rückendeckung ja
also die Philippinen gelten aus
Drehscheibe der politischen Rivalität
zwischen den beiden großen Mächten ja
also die Szenarien dieser dreiwöchigen
Übungen betreffen die Verteidigung des
philippinischen Archipels gegen mögliche
ausländische Angreifer ja
dieser mögliche Angreifer hat gerade
drei Tage lang rund um Taiwan die
Muskeln spielen lassen China betrachtete
die demokratische Insel als Teil seines
Staatsgebiets das Ziel die
Wiedervereinigung wie es in der
Propaganda heißt
taiwan hat nicht nur einen
geopolitischen Wert für China und die
USA sondern die ganze Hightech Welt
hängt am Tropf der Insel die ganze
Halbleiterindustrie vor allem wenn wir
wirklich über die ganz hoch
spezialisierten ganz kleine Chips reden
92% kommen ja Auszahlung Chips für Autos
Handys Laptops durch sie hört die ganze
Welt das Echo dasselbe Rasselns auf
beiden Seiten des Südchinesischen Meers
und jetzt wie angekündigt ein Gespräch
insbesondere zu Marcos Aussagen mit dem
CDU aus dem Politiker Norbert Röttgen
und damit einen schönen guten Abend
einen guten
sie sagen macron scheint von allen guten
Geistern verlassen warum ganz genau was
ist so verwerflich an seinen Aussagen
ja das völlig unverständliche ist in
einer Situation in der Amerika der
größte Unterstützer der Ukraine ist die
von Russland angegriffen ist wieder mal
die europäische sicherheitsmacht in
dieser Zeit fordert macron eine Abkehr
eine Entfernung von Amerika und
gleichzeitig in einer Situation in der
China den Angriff auf Taiwan übt
propagiert er eine Annäherung an China
und übernimmt auch was Taiwan anbelangt
das chinesische narrativ das macht
keinen Sinn dass isoliert ihn und hat
ihn isoliert leider in Europa ist
spaltet Europa es wirft Fragen auch über
die Zuverlässigkeit Europas also es ist
ein großer Schaden entstanden ohne dass
es dafür irgendein plausiblen Grund gibt
den irgendeine erkennen könnte aber nur
weil die USA die Ukraine unterstützen
und damit ja auch Europa verteidigen ist
das ja aber kein Grund sich nicht
unabhängiger von den USA zu machen das
machen die ja zum Beispiel auch durch
den Inflation reduction Act also der
europäische Unternehmen vom US-Markt
ausschließt aber die Frage die mich
interessiert was glauben Sie denn warum
Marco diesen Alleingang diese Äußerungen
jetzt getätigt hat will er wirklich
Europa Spalten es ist eine Inszenierung
es ist ein innenpolitisches Signal
noch mal in der Sache ja natürlich wir
müssen als Europäer stärker werden aber
natürlich nicht gegen die USA sondern
mit den USA das wollen die USA auch aber
nur gemeinsam sind wir stark das erleben
wir doch auch gerade wir haben ja eine
sehr
bündnisorientierte amerikanische
Administration gerade was ihn dazu
bringt ich muss sagen ich kann es nicht
verstehen es versteht auch keiner auch
innenpolitisch macht der damit nicht
wirklich Punkte ist auch innenpolitisch
in Frankreich kritisiert worden
ich weiß es ich muss wirklich sagen ob
es nur das Ego ist dass in drei ich ich
kann keinen Grund finden es ist wirklich
eine unverantwortliche Position wieso
sehen Sie denn in macrons Aussagen eher
eine Annäherung an China statt eine
besondere Unabhängigkeit von den USA die
ja spätestens nach dem Erfolg von Trump
und wer weiß was kommt von vielen in
Europa ja auch gefordert wurde
noch mal Unabhängigkeit mehr Stärke
Europas also Frankreich leistet
bescheidenste Beiträge zu Unterstützung
der Ukraine jeder ist aufgerufen mehr zu
tun das ist das was nötig ist aber
Ernährung an China liegt darin dass er
das ist glaube ich da verheerendste Satz
in der gesprochen hat er hat gewarnt
davor dass die USA uns in den Konflikt
mit China um Taiwan hineinzieht ein
Konflikt der uns nichts angehen die
Wahrheit ist das China
Taiwan mit Krieg droht also nicht die
USA ziehen herein sondern China droht
mit Krieg und wenn es zu diesem Krieg
kommt dann hat das verheerende
strategische globale Auswirkungen denn
jetzt aber China und ich bin zu sagen du
kannst uns vielleicht Spalten von den
Amerikanern wir sind nicht einig das ist
eher eine Verlockung diesen Krieg
anzufangen als eine Abschreckung und das
Wichtigste ist dass wir dies dass wir
alles tun was möglich ist diesen Krieg
zu verhindern und er tut er leider das
Gegenteil und das ist ziemlich
dramatisch also
sagen fallen ja in der Tat in eine Zeit
in der China Angriffe auf Tai waren in
den letzten Tagen simuliert hat er
plädiert jetzt dafür sich aus diesem
Konflikt sie haben es gerade gesagt
rauszuhalten sie sieht twittern wiederum
wir stehen bei einem Angriff an der
Seite Taiwans was will denn Europa
wirklich konkret machen wenn China Teil
wann angreift also was mehr als
moralische Unterstützung
wir stehen auf der Seite und auf den
Boden einer regelbasierten Ordnung wir
stehen gegen Gewalt wenn das das Prinzip
ist was China möchte dass chinesische
macht zählt dann haben wir eine
Weltordnung die nicht unser Interesse
ist was wir machen werden nicht
militärisch da haben wir gar nichts auf
die Waage zu bringen um es mal ganz klar
zu sagen aber es wird wirtschaftliche
Sanktionen gegen China geben das ist
ohne jede Frage der Fall und weil wir
eine zu große industrielle
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit von China
haben die der reduzieren müssen die
müssen wir reduzieren hätte in diesem
Fall China gegen gerade gegen
Deutschland ein ziemlich verheerendes
wirtschaftliches vergeltungspotenzial
mit seinen Sanktionen also diese
Abhängigkeit die müssen wir reduzieren
weil sie unsere Souveränität unsere
Handlungsfähigkeit beeinträchtigt also
gerade andersherum ja und die lange
angekündigte China Strategie der
Bundesregierung lässt ja auch noch auf
sich warten warten wer ab was der Besuch
der Außenministerin diese Woche in China
bringt noch einmal zurück nach
Frankreich aus dem elyseepalast heißt es
ja jetzt die USA sind unsere Verbündeten
China hingegen sei Partner Konkurrent
und systemischer Rivale mit dem man eine
gemeinsame Agenda schaffen wolle
umspannungen zu reduzieren wenn
Frankreich in China ein Partner sieht
und China vielleicht auch in Frankreich
hilft das eventuell in Bezug auf den
Krieg in die Russen führen oder ist es
naiv
nein das ist wirklich keine realistische
Einschätzung wir wollen Partnerschaft
wir brauchen sie auch mit China in
manchen Bereichen wenn es zum Beispiel
darum geht den Klimawandel einzugrenzen
zu stoppen dann geht das nicht ohne
China aber China hat macht politisch
eine eindeutige Agenda china will eine
andere Weltordnung das was wir die
liberale Rechtsordnung nennen das ist
für China alles amerikanischer
Machtanspruch und China möchte diese
Ordnung ersetzen durch eine Ordnung die
die chinesische macht die respektiert
sie haben eben über das südchinesische
mehr berichtet das wird reklamiert
völkerrechtswidrig als Hoheitsgebiet
Chinas und China erwartet dass das die
Welt respektiert das ist die Weltordnung
die China ist strebt und mit Macht und
System geht China voran sagt Norbert
Röttgen CDU aus dem Politiker vielen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit
ich danke Ihnen sehr Frau herrling und
um
null Uhr 30 im heute journal Update dann
zum gleichen Thema der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Europäischen
Volkspartei Manfred Weber der ja auch
stellvertretender Parteivorsitzender der
CSU und damit blicken wir jetzt in die
USA dort geht ja das Rätselraten über
die veröffentlichten Geheimdokumente
weiter wer hat die sensiblen Daten die
ja auch den Krieg gegen die Ukraine
betreffen gelegt wie groß ist der
Schaden tatsächlich was bedeutet das
alles für das Vertrauensverhältnis zu
den US-Verbündeten fragen über Fragen
doch die Antworten fallen schwer wenn er
mir Daniel
das aus dem berühmtesten Fünfeck der
Welt Geheimnisse nach außen dringend
äußerst selten und dass der Sprecher des
Nationalen Sicherheitsrats im Weißen
Haus auch Tage nach den
Veröffentlichungen sagt er wisse nicht
wer dahinter stecke und was dann noch
kommen können ist mindestens genauso
bemerkenswert
schenkt unsere Möglichkeiten ein
Informationen zu bekommen er wirkt sich
auf unsere Methoden unsere Quellen unser
Verhältnis zu unseren Verbündeten aus
und nicht zu vergessen er beschädigt das
Vertrauen in unsere Regierung und
Ministerien Geheimnisse bewahren zu
können
es sind unter anderem diese Dokumente
über deren Echtheit und Herkunft
gestritten wird in den sozialen Medien
werden zahlreiche gefälschte Versionen
für Propaganda Zwecke verbreitet manche
der rund 100 geliebten Papiere scheinen
aber tatsächlich hochsensible Daten zu
enthalten glaubt die US-Regierung
es gibt keine Entschuldigung dafür dass
solche Dokumente in der Öffentlichkeit
auftauchen
sie sollten auf keinen Fall öffentlich
sondern streng geheim gehalten sein
vieles rund um die leaks ist nach wie
vor unklar was wir bisher wissen die
Dokumente bieten einen Einblick in die
lagebewertung des Krieges Anfang März
sie enthalten taktische Informationen
über die ukrainische Luftabwehr und die
internationalen Bemühungen die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu
unterstützen außerdem Hinweise auf
bisher unbekannte Möglichkeiten
russische militärkommunikation abzuhören
Satelliten Spionage wie das sogenannte
lapis-programm das wohl best gehütete
Geheimnis der us-luftaufklärung
unter Berufung auf die Dokumente
berichten sowohl die New York Times als
auch die Washington Post das US-Militärs
an der Schlagkraft der geplanten
Frühjahrsoffensive der Ukraine zweifeln
in Kiew hingegen will man davon nichts
wissen und spielt die Veröffentlichungen
herunter derweil Rad Militärexperten zur
Vorsicht bei der Bewertung
diese leaks unterscheiden sich von
früheren wie den Snowden leaks oder
Wikileaks da ging es um komplett echte
Papiere die gesicherte Informationen
enthielten viele der nun
veröffentlichten Dokumente enthalten
Falschinformationen oder sind
irreführend
sie wurden manipuliert und unterscheiden
sich von den Originalen das wissen wir
bereits und dazu mischen sich dann echte
Dokumente und echte Geheimnisse
die Suche nach Antworten geht weiter wie
groß der Schaden am Ende tatsächlich ist
auch im Hinblick auf das
Vertrauensverhältnis zu den US
Verbündeten ist im Moment noch schwer
abzusehen
und unklar ist auch welche Folgen das
alles für die Ukraine haben wird
schalten wir dorthin zu unserem Reporter
daran
man hört von dort ja relativ wenig kaum
Reaktion woran liegt das eigentlich
ja die Regierung hier die vermittelt ein
Bild die ganze Welt ist den Aufruhr nur
die Ukraine nicht man spielt die leaks
herunter als bekannt wurde dass das
Telefon von selensky Präsident selensky
angezapft und mit abgehört war wurde da
wie hieß es einfach aus
Regierungskreisen man habe volles
Vertrauen in die USA und man wisst ja
auch nicht hundert Prozent ob das Stimme
und die ganzen militärischen Daten die
herauskamen die alle würden die groß die
geplante Großoffensive nicht sonderlich
beeinträchtigen und mit dieser Haltung
erreichen sie eigentlich auch die
Bevölkerung hier habe ich ähm auch nicht
festgestellt dass das große Aufregung
herrscht dass das große Rede Thema war
ich habe heute bei Soldaten gedreht die
mit Drohnen operieren und da sagte einer
zu mir das ist sehr interessant was als
nächstes kommt dann weiß man vielleicht
mehr und im übrigen so ein Skandal kann
man sowieso nur aus der Zukunft in einem
Rückblick richtig bewerten und damit wir
da wohl auch recht haben
vielen Dank daran HD zu dieser
Einordnung zu den Reaktionen oder nicht
Reaktion aus der Ukraine zu den Links
ja und hier in Deutschland geht der
Streit über die Nutzung der Atomkraft
weiter kurz bevor die drei letzten Meile
am Samstag abgeschaltet werden sollen
und damit beginnen die Nachrichten
Gundula ja Kritik kommt erneut vor allem
von Vertretern der Wirtschaft und der
Union
Fraktionsvize Spahn appellierte an die
FDP den Atomausstieg zu verhindern das
Aus für die Atomkraft sei ein schwarzer
Tag für den Klimaschutz in Deutschland
sagte er der ARD der Wirtschaftsverband
DIHK warnte vor
Versorgungsengpässen für Unternehmen und
wie der steigenden Energiepreisen
dagegen sieht Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck die Energieversorgung ohne
Atomkraft gewährleistet und hält trotz
aller Widerstände am Atomausstieg fest
in Deutschland laufen 185 Zivilklagen
wegen möglicher Schäden durch
corona-impfungen nach Angaben zweier
Anwaltskanzleien die die Betroffenen
vertreten wird in allen Fällen per
Gutachten geprüft ob z.B ein Herzschaden
tatsächlich durch eine corona-impfung
verursacht wurde die Klagen richten sich
gegen alle vier großen
Impfstoffhersteller deren
Haftungsrisiken vom Staat übernommen
wurden
der türkische Präsident Erdogan und
seine islamisch konservative AKP Partei
haben den Wahlkampf für die parlaments-
und Präsidentenwahl im Mai gestartet
dabei versprach Erdogan mehr Geld für
Beamte und Rentner wegen einer
Wirtschaftskrise und 50% Inflation sowie
schlechten Krisenmanagements nach dem
Erdbeben im Februar muss Erdogan um
seine Macht fürchten
aussichtsreichste Gegenkandidat ist der
Chef der Mitte Linkspartei CHP
chilitarulu der für ein breites
Oppositionsbündnis antritt in
Großbritannien sind fast 50.000
Assistenzärzte der Krankenhäuser in
einen viertägigen Streik getreten
dadurch fallen rund 350.000 Termine und
auch viele Operationen aus so
Verantwortliche der staatlichen
Gesundheitssystems
die Assistenzärzte fordern 35% mehr
Gehalt in den vergangenen 15 Jahren sein
ihre Einkünfte durch die Inflation um
ein Viertel geschrumpft die britische
Regierung nannte die Forderungen
unangemessen
es ist nicht das erste mal und da die
internationale Weltgemeinschaft zur Zeit
auch nicht mehr so ganz genau
hinzuschauen scheint möglicherweise auch
nicht das letzte Mal jedenfalls wurden
in Iran erneut dutzende SchülerInnen in
mehreren Regionen vergiftet Eltern sind
verärgert darüber dass keine Aufklärung
durch den Staat stattfindet der kündigt
zwar an harte Strafen in irgendeiner
Weise durchzusetzen geht dann aber doch
lieber weiter gegen Frauen vor die den
Job nicht tragen
hört das erst auf wenn Sie unsere Kinder
getötet haben schreit eine Mutter wo ist
die Schuldirektorin sie ist drin sagt
ein Mädchen aber sie hat sich versteckt
ein Mädchengymnasium in Istan
Schülerinnen Ringen um Luft wieder ein
Angriff mit Reizgas es hört nicht auf
warum schützt dir unsere Kinder nicht
fragen sich viele und haben den Verdacht
dass das Regime selbst dahinter steckt
ich glaube sie wollen den Mädchen Angst
einjagen wegen der letzten Proteste sie
haben herausgefunden wer mitgemacht hat
und wollen sie nun bestrafen
fest steht nur dass es sich um Reizgas
handelt wie es ausgebracht wird und von
wem ist nicht geklärt und offenbar haben
es die Behörden auch nicht eilig damit
es herauszubekommen anders so meint er
Soziologe Ahmad bucherei sei kaum zu
erklären warum diese Anschläge im
Überwachungsstaat Iran nicht verhindert
werden können
die Angreifer mit dem inneren Zirkel der
Macht verbunden sein beantwortet sich
die Frage warum die Täter nicht
ermittelt und ernsthaft verfolgt werden
von selbst
die Betroffenen sind wütend und
verzweifelt die meisten anderen im Land
sind fassungslos
die Regierung gibt kein gutes Bild ab
ich bin sicher würde es sich um ein
anderes Thema Handeln hätten sie es viel
schneller verfolgt
ihn ist es wichtiger dass Frauen das
Kopftuch richtig tragen als das Leben
von Kindern zu retten
damit es solche Bilder in Zukunft nicht
mehr gibt schreitet Irans Führung sehr
viel konsequenter zur Tat um Frauen
aufzuspüren die das Kopftuch nicht oder
nicht vorschriftsgemäß tragen soll aber
jetzt verstärkt Kameraüberwachung auf
den Straßen eingesetzt werden
wir werden moderne Technologie einsetzen
um die Personen zu identifizieren die
Frauen bekommen eine Verwarnung im
Wiederholungsfall werden ihre Akten den
Justizbehörden übergeben
bereits jetzt wird Frauen in Teheran die
gegen die Kopftuch Regeln verstoßen der
Zutritt zur öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln
Banken und vielen Einkaufszentren
verweigert
wir müssen uns an die Job gesetzte
halten wenn wir keinen Ärger haben und
Konsequenzen vermeiden wollen aber etwas
das dir aufgezwungen wird ist niemals
angenehm
es gibt andere Sachen die wichtiger sind
als der Job wie die Lebensbedingungen
der Menschen und die instabile
wirtschaftliche Lage
die iranische Führung aber fürchte den
macht Verlust wenn der Kopftuch Zwang
fällt ihn zu verteidigen scheint
wichtiger als alles andere
und jetzt noch mal Nachrichten aus der
Welt Sports und der Wirtschaft der
Internationale Währungsfonds hat seine
Wachstumsprognose nach unten korrigiert
und erwartet für Deutschland in diesem
Jahr eine leichte Rezession
zuversichtlicher waren gerade führende
deutsche Wirtschaftsinstitute die mit
einem Mini-Wachstum rechnen wir fragen
Sina meine an der Börse warum schätzt
der IWF die Lage riskante ein ja weil
einfach zu viele Unwegbarkeiten die
deutsche Wirtschaft erschüttern deshalb
ist die Prognose auch nach unten
korrigiert worden und wird mit den
wirtschaftlichen Folgen der
corona-pandemie und des Ukraine Krieges
begründet ebenso mit den hohen
Verbraucherpreisen und zu guter Letzt
auch mit den Turbulenzen im Bankensektor
hier wart der Internationale
Währungsfonds vor einer stockenden
Kreditvergabe auch diese könnte die
Wirtschaft zusätzlich ausbremsen heißt
es laut internationalem Währungsfond
werden die meisten Industriestaaten zwar
eine schwache Konjunktur erleben eine
Rezession aber gerade so entgehen anders
sieht es hierzulande aus der IWF rechnet
damit dass die deutsche Wirtschaft um
0,1% schrumpfen wird erst im kommenden
Jahr soll es dann wieder bergauf gehen
ja und auch die Weltbank nimmt ja an der
Tagung morgen teil und muss auf globale
Krisen reagieren was steht da an eine
ganze Menge steht da auf der Agenda die
globalen Wirtschaftsaussichten sind mau
und das wird schwächere Länder dann
besonders hart ein zentraler Punkt wird
wohl sein wie soll dort Wachstum
geschaffen werden die Schulden für
ärmere Länder werden durch die
steigenden Zinsen noch teurer sie sind
deutlich stärker von der Klimakrise
betroffen und leiden noch mehr unter den
hohen Lebensmittelpreisen die
Erderwärmung eindämmen und Armut
bekämpfen diese zwei Themen sind eng
miteinander verwoben und werden ganz
oben auf dem Programm stehen das Ziel
der Weltbank war einmal bis zum Jahr
2030 bittere Armut besiegt zu haben doch
das scheint inzwischen zeitlich nicht
mehr erreichbar zu sein
vielen Dank nach Frankfurt
mindestens einmal jede Nacht wird
statistisch irgendwo in Deutschland ein
Geldautomat gesprengt deswegen erwägen
Bund und Länder gesetzliche Vorgaben für
Banken damit diese ihre Geldautomaten
sicherer machen etwa durch einfärbe und
Klebesysteme um das gestohlene Bargeld
unbrauchbar zu machen oder
vernebelungstechnik der zuständige
Dachverband der Kreditwirtschaft lehnt
die kostenintensiven Pläne ab
ein Vulkanausbruch im fernen Osten
Russlands auf der Pazifik Halbinsel
Kamtschatka beschäftigt dort die rund
300.000 Bewohner sie sind allerdings
Vulkanausbrüche gewöhnt denn wieder ist
einer der etwa 30 Vulkane aktiv der
skiverletsch stößt bis zu 20 km hohe
Aschewolken aus der Flugverkehr ist
bislang nur lokal beeinträchtigt und am
Boden 9 cm hoch Asche
noch eine Meldung vom Frauenfußball die
deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat genau
100 Tage vor Beginn der Frauenfußball WM
einen stimmungsdämpfer hinnehmen müssen
eine eins zu zwei Niederlage gegen
Brasilien in Nürnberg erzählte Jule
Brand in der 91 minute den deutschen
Treffer die Vize Europameisterinnen
gehen ab dem 20 Juni mit Bundestrainerin
von Tecklenburg an die konkrete
Vorbereitung der WM in Australien und
Neuseeland im Sommer
und ich melde mich später noch einmal
mit dem heute journal Update darin auch
ein Spielbericht aus der Champions
League Viertelfinale Hinspiel Manchester
City gegen Bayern München und uns beide
zusammen gibt's am Morgen wieder um 9:45
Uhr bis dahin machen sie es gut wo auch
immer Sie sind schon Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter neuer Regen kommt
auf und zwar mit diesem T4 und das
Frontensystem zu diesem tiefer erreichte
uns in der zweiten Nachthälfte und da
kommt Regen auf sonst nach ostenden
zeitweise noch trocken in der Nacht also
aufkommender Regen ganz im Westen
Deutschlands und der breitet sich
langsam aus in den östlichen
Landesteilen trocken die letzten Schauer
hier im Osten ziehen ab und dann wird
auch dort trocken Temperaturen gehen
zurück auf -1° im Osten Deutschlands
hier also leichter Frost am mildesten
entlang des Rheins mit 6 bis 9 Grad und
morgen am Vormittag zwischen Oder und
Neiße bis Richtung Erzgebirge
trockenteils mit Sonnenschein auch ganz
im Süden zwischendurch mal aufgelockert
und Sonne sonst aber viele Wolken und
dazu Regen und auffrischender Wind aus
Südwest und zum Nachmittag lockert es
von am besten her wiederum auf aber
schauen und Gewitter bilden sich ganz im
Osten zieht es zu und auch hier kommt
nun allmählich Regen auf die
Temperaturen erreichen höchste Werte von
9 Grad zum Beispiel in
Schleswig-Holstein und 16 Grad am
wärmsten ganz im Süden Deutschlands die
nächsten Tage sind unbeständig am
Donnerstag im Osten sonniger Abschnitte
aber sonst ist Regen dabei an den alten
Feld um 1000 Meter Schnee 5 bis 13 Grad
und am Freitag weiterhin an den alten
Schneefall im Westen sonniger und vor
allem Samstag unbeständig aber wärmer
damit ein schöner Abend